We just talked about random testing in this larger context as part of the software process.
What I'd like to talk about now is one of the more advanced and frankly difficult
parts of building a really good random test case generally.
As I was saying a little while ago, the best way to start random testing
started early in the software process and starts simple, and what's going to come out
of a simple random test case generator is often a collection of
testing results that are not particularly great.
That is to say we get shallow coverage, we violate many constraints on valid inputs
and overall it doesn't work all that well, and probably we doesn't find that all many bugs
and that's for testing a particularly weak system like for example,
the UNIX command line utilities from around 1990.
The thing to do with these results, look hard at the test cases.
Think hard about how they relate to the overall shape of the input domain for the system.
For example, it maybe that we are generating a super set of the input domain
that is to say we're generating invalid inputs,
but it's also likely that in many cases we're generating a subset of the domain.
That is to say we're generating test cases that fail to explore some parts of the behavior space
of the software under test, and that's going to lead to missed bugs.
You should definitely look at the fact that the random test cases have on code coverage.
Often this is extremely revealing cause as we've seen,
it's really easy to write a random test case generator.
It gets very shallow coverage of the software under test.
The next step, here's what you've learn
to adjust the rules that are in the fact for generating random test cases and to tweak the probabilities.
If that sounds very vague at this point, then that's good because it is very vague.
What I'm going to do a little bit is going to some specific examples.
Of course, we can also add functionality to our random tester.
As I was saying earlier, it's often good to do this in a very slow and incremental fashion
so we avoid overloading people with bugs that they don't have time to fix,
and this is an iterative process that doesn't stop as long as we're using the random tester.
We should sort of kind of keep looking at it and trying to evaluate how we can better
adjust the random tester to find interesting things out about the software that we're testing,
and I don't mean to say here that this has to take a lot of time.
Something you do is just anytime you have time every couple a weeks or whenever,
just take a look at the test cases, take a look at the coverage, think about things a little bit,
see if anything has changed in the software under test that might make you want to
tweak the random tester, and basically you just to put it back into production.